all right let's get into this game oh
wow the great outdoors I think I'll stay
inside thank you very much oh well I
guess there's no choice I have to go
outside there's no internet I must go to
my neighbors this is a really great game
so far let's go to our neighbors and ask
for their Wi-Fi other doors open well
don't mind if I let myself in what hey I
think a demon lives in here that's cool
as long as they have Wi-Fi oh wow
I've heard great things about this game
but I really gotta say that you know I
get it I get it you don't want me to
steal Wi-Fi I can respect that
but that's not gonna stop me from
getting that where there is that son of
a [ __ ]
he's italiano those stupid of a Funko
italiano I need to get in that room
let's look at the back to her Oh could
this be a point of entry perhaps oh yes
the Wi-Fi will be mine mmm I'm in ok why
don't we get hello that's a lot of
shampoo for one man something is wrong
here something is clearly wrong
well this is creepy where is he where is
he
video sir Oh shush oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ
what's the matter with my neighbor
I will girders Wi-Fi new attempt let's
not walk in front of the surveillance
system this time okay all right he's God
Chinese food and he likes boys that's
all right so do i what do we have in the
fridge
who keeps apples in their fridge
something's clearly not right here
I need that Wi-Fi damn it it must be
here somewhere
yesterday and we're fair oh [ __ ] oh oh
no oh Jesus Christ do so squish oh why
am i scared by playing this game it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense for the
fifth time I'm gonna get dead welfare
here we go ah thought no no I'm stuck
again [ __ ] is coming up oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what I do
cama
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is this game it's so weird
why am i stalking my neighbor it doesn't
make any sense
hey pop but up mana and Dan buddy
well if you can't hear that he must be
dead somebody once told me the world is
there's a bucket trap the famous bucket
trap what oh [ __ ] I fell in the bucket
trap
all right the bear trap again no no no
no no oh why am I scared of him all
right so there is a room that I need to
get into but there's a pass code and I
need to get through hopefully I can do
it
without stepping on the [ __ ] bear
traps where is he this is oh [ __ ] I [ __ ]
I [ __ ] quit the game Jesus Christ
damn it I can do this shut shut up I can
do this I know what I'm doing stop it
I don't see him you know it bothers me
that I can't see him hello let's just
walk slowly very slowly slowly oh my god
it's the Illuminati I know wait
Jesus Christ what was that hello mister
neighbor I just put a pie here here good
on that bar please do not [ __ ] me
take it oh where does he come from
you know what I'm [ __ ] pissed now hey
you tallien scum I'm coming for you
let's try and go upstairs oh my god
let's not go upstairs that's the room we
need to get into ok alright
[ __ ] how do I get out of the beer trash
I'm free I'm free in a bear trap [ __ ]
what'd I do now
the box so bad at this game it's painful
hey buddy you want to borrow Joe why am
I so scared of these stupid-ass stupid
game I'm not sketch shut up I'm not
scared
George stupid sounds it's just a sounds
it's just an Italian guy I'm not scared
of Italian man stupid everyone [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] game hey [ __ ] it
oh he locks his door now what a dick
take a box oh [ __ ] I broke his house
back to my house
you can't come to my house you can't
come to my house can it ha ha ha ha
that's [ __ ] right my house my [ __ ]
ass oh that's right you get up into a
bear trap at me
they threw apples at me hey listen here
you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] damn it
well it's back to 2015 Peter Pan just
screaming at video games we're up
alright well this has been a great game
thank you
gobble will now take over go ahead Gavin
oh my God he's coming for my Pepsi gob
of Jesus wait I'll play you direct me
you have to go next
Nick next destiny there's a key it's TV
you just broke into his own house did
you see that it's perfect okay what do I
need oh [ __ ] where oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I hate this game Michael do something oh
[ __ ] I hear me hear me shut up shut up
[ __ ] the hammer where's the hammer
there's no boiler room where do I go
Michael thank you I am in the back of
the house oh you mean this yeah there's
a bear trap ah [ __ ]
where where's the hammer Michael
where's the hammer whoa whoa whoa
look he's breaking into his own house
here he's so stupid look at him oh Jesus
Christ
you never know what the [ __ ] he's gonna
do
No
what the [ __ ] what did this nah come on
market you were supposed to help me I
[Music]
have returned never never in my 84 I
mean in my six years of being on YouTube
have I been this pissed at a game that's
not true I challenged this game I'm
gonna beat this game no matter what the
[ __ ] I do I'm [ __ ] paste now
apparently he learns he learns my
movements and he will know what to
expect so I will give him the unexpected
it's time here we go
are there yes see there's the cake
there's the key we gotta distract him
plaint go
oh [ __ ] why am I so bad at this [ __ ]
game jesus [ __ ] christ
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn me [ __ ] no hey
fish
[Music]
and I'm talking about God with your
parents and teachers want you to be with
you I'm talking about figuring out for
yourselves what makes you happy no
matter how crazy it may sound he's gone
Pete's gone it's gone it's gone I got
the King used to go number three use the
KP used to feel okay [ __ ] ever attempted
[ __ ] okay dropping key to fail yeah win
but don't be afraid of making decisions
you can't be paralyzed and vo failure
that's why I push yourself you keep
pushing because you believe in yourself
and in your vision and you know my god
thing to do and success will come so
don't feel i everything doesn't work
bring the key where's the key there's no
key oh wait this is it
now what open I have the key what do you
think I'm doing
[Music]
it's been days I haven't been able to
finish the game I just can't do it I
just can't do so we're just gonna look
up online why cuz I really want to know
what's in the room it has to be
something good
hello neighbor game ending alright 475
475 yeah that's it
oh my god here it is I'm in I'm in hey
what's out here nothing not even Harry
Potter not even Harry Potter oh not even
Harry Potter not even [ __ ] Harry
Potter do you hear that gabble not even
[ __ ] Harry Potter
not even Harry Potter Jesus well that's
a pretty good game I really enjoyed it I
think it's a really good game I'm really
glad that you guys recommended this
really good game please leave a like as
a as a thanks for nothing nothing there
was nothing there was nothing and as
always stay awesome browse
[Music]
you